over the past few months Riot Games has
been under a ton of criticism current
and former employees have accused a
company of fostering a toxic sexist
workplace culture and breaking
California labor laws which all led to a
walkout last month and based on how it
went
we're in for a lot more action basically
riot is in hot water and today we want
to walk you through that and explain how
we got here
[Music]
so what's going on at riot well the
public side of all this started last
year when Cecilia Donna Stasi Oh a
senior reporter Kotaku wrote a feature
that detailed the sexist culture at Riot
Games
I spoke with about two dozen current and
former employees at riot and riot is a
company that has over 2,500 employees
eighty percent of whom are men in the
initial report and aside from the simple
gender makeup that's something that
might exist in any studio employees a
riot had issues with hiring and
promoting women men being promoted into
positions that women were just as
qualified before but the men might have
been friends with the boss there were
issues with regard to listening to women
in meetings or interrupting them there
were a lot of issues with regard to
speaking in a sexual manner toward
female in Kali for example like one said
that she saw an email chain about what
it would be like to penetrate her
another one said that there was a list
that senior leaders were passing around
with the hottest women at the company
and someone told that to her as like a
compliment you have to remember that
writers are humans which means that
stuff like that it affects more than
just their salary or what job they're
doing in fact their mental health it's
difficult because women who work at riot
want to work for riot but people who
love League of Legends who love gaming
and for a lot of people this was a dream
job something that always wanted to do
but I had a lot of sources talk to me
about how they would go home crying or
they would leave the office and go and
cry in their car hyperventilate because
frankly the way they were treated drove
them a little bit crazy imagine if every
day you came into work and you had a
colleague who was not as good at their
job they had five years less experience
than you but you know they thought that
your boss is humping other male
colleagues or you know sticking their
balls in their face was funny and that
person got promoted and you didn't that
would drive anyone crazy and it would
make anyone want you know to question
whether they should be at that company
or in the games industry at all there's
a pretty high
emotional and mental costs to working in
a toxic environment being passed up for
promotion for someone less qualified
seems innocuous on the surface but when
it keeps happening I can really [ __ ] you
up
and that's before we get to the most
disgusting behavior one of the things
that a lot of sources told me is that a
lot of these things weren't over I did
hear some instances of sexual predation
or assault at riot but most of what went
on was kind of subtle sort of
microaggressions things like just
talking over women in meetings or a man
presenting the same idea as a woman and
getting praised for it where you know
the woman's idea was kind of shot down
and people didn't talk about this they
didn't feel comfortable addressing
issues of imbalance and how people
treated other peoples different genders
which is really interesting because like
I said before riots culture really
values feedback and direct feedback when
that comes to work and when that comes
to performance but when it comes to kind
of cultural stuff along these lines more
sensitive issues that stuff was kind of
swept under the rug now it wasn't just
specific actions taking against women
either Anastasio reported that one
person riot CEO Scott yelled was a huge
proponent of the generally toxic
environment at Riot Games a lot of
people told me that he was known to
heart on employees faces if women
weren't meetings he would pump male
employees he would ball tap people super
broke culture kind of like fraternity
stuff imagine walking into a meeting and
your boss farts in your face or grabs
your genitals it's legitimately awful I
cannot imagine it the first time you
hear about stuff like that happening you
kind of want to laugh because it sounds
so ridiculous than it be impossible but
if your boss actually did that to you
he'd be living in a nightmare
now following Donna Stassi owes articles
Gelb was put on a two months of leave
but he's still at the company something
a lot of employees allegedly still take
issue with before we get to that though
there's something interesting that I
want to note in August 2018 Donna Stasi
reported that Marc Mero got on stage at
an apology for riots toxic workplace
culture and cried and then Gelb got on
stage and to remind you that
who was allegedly farting on faces and
grabbing genitals it seems kind of wild
to me personally that there's such a
disconnect here that someone can have
such a genuine emotional reaction to a
problem at the place they found it and
then cede the stage to one of the
perpetrators of the issue they feel so
badly about so I asked Anastasio how
does this happen
riot like a lot of tech companies is
very obsessed with the idea or was very
obsessed with the idea of a meritocracy
so the people who are most deserving
should be the most successful and the
most rewarded and nobody would argue
that you know that's not a great idea in
theory like of course people who work
the hardest and are the most talented
and contribute the most to the success
of the company should reap the rewards
of that and receive a lot of praise what
there was no understanding of at the
time supporting the story is why people
of some demographics might have a harder
time fitting into that ideal or
succeeding at the company than others so
for example I grew up as a woman and I
was not somebody who was encouraged to
play video games I was not given video
games by family members I was given
Barbie dolls
I was not encouraged to play
counter-strike and talk on Ventrilo with
my guy friends even though I did that I
didn't have Xbox parties the gaming DNA
is woven into the young male experience
in a way that it's kind of not for women
and that's not because women don't like
video games it's because this is how
games were marketed at that time and I
think Riot was really looking for people
who grew up being gamers and you know PC
master-race
type people and if you are somebody who
might have come to that more recently
and maybe are no less passionate than
somebody who had been gaming their whole
life then things would be more difficult
for you and it might be more difficult
for you to scale the ladder there this
mostly brings us up to last month when
several ride employees walked out of
their office in protest specifically
they were protesting riots policy of
using force binding arbitration in cases
that
involves sexual harassment or
discrimination what that means is that
ride employees didn't have the right to
sue their employer in the case that they
experienced sexual harassment or
discrimination instead they submitted
their case to an arbitrator who made a
final judgment no appeals and Wray gets
to choose the arbitrator that means that
if you experience sexual harassment at
riot say somebody grabbed your genitals
riot picks the person who decides what
happens which puts the power squarely on
a riot side
what employee sued riot for the
harassment and discrimination they faced
at work right try to force them into
arbitration which is what kick-started
the walkouts now before the walkouts
right did actually make a change their
forced arbitration policy new employees
will be able to opt out of forced
arbitration once current litigation is
over that means once riot deals with all
of these lawsuits presumably enforce
arbitration new employees won't have to
deal with all of that that was really
not enough for most riders especially
those involved in that current
litigation so the walkouts went ahead
according to various reports on the
walkouts last month organizers were
demanding an end to forced arbitration
and that many of the people
participating in the walkout felt that
they were tired of ride protecting
people who were responsible for the very
thing they were trying to sue Ryan over
now we reached out to riot and they
mostly linked us to a bunch of material
that's are even out there for a while
but we should still go over it in the
interest of being fair shortly after the
walkout right put out a statement about
what they're doing to answer some of the
issues people had with the company the
first thing is the diversity and
inclusion rider council a group that
right wants to form to keep discussions
about those topics going in a formal
capacity and address the issues that
people have with the company they also
have a group of riders reviewing the
code of conduct to help make it more
representative of the company as a whole
a lot of this is about mitigating and
hopefully preventing the issues that
riders that don estado spoke to faced
and that's admirable there's a lot on
Wright's website about what they're
trying to do to fix those problems but
there's nothing on that website about
ending forced arbitration the most we
got on that specific issue from riot was
this well we ultimately made the choice
not to change our arbitration policy
while in active litigation to give
credit to everyone that participated in
the walkout it's important to point out
that these changes were directly as a
result of what we heard from riders at
walk out and in the lead up to it we
reached out to the walkout organizers
but unfortunately didn't receive a
comment in time for publication but what
we do know from what they said to other
outlets is that there will be further
action speaking to go talk to one of the
organizers Indu Reddy said that they
have plans for further action in that
retaliation is an ongoing concern as of
Monday June 10th Reddy is no longer at
riot she declined to comment as to why
and we're not gonna speculate on that so
what's next well the riot walkout saw a
lot of support from all over the games
industry and another walkout organizer
Jocelyn Monaghan told The Verge that
they have no intention of stopping and
all the support they saw is a big part
of what's keeping them going in my
opinion that's where the fans come in
well it's easy to play a video game and
forget that it's made by humans humans
who love making games and love making
sure that you have the most fun possible
playing them and every cool moment
you've ever had playing League of
Legends has been touched at least in
some small way by one of those people at
riot and they deserve to feel safe at
work anyone should have empathy for the
sources I interviewed for the story and
especially sources who faced harassment
unwanted Commons in any sort of
discrimination I just want people to
think a little bit about how important
it is for the people who make video
games to represent the people who play
them thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]